time now for today's speed round brought
to you by verizon
5g built right let's get into it
if the courtship for jj watt comes down
to two teams it'll be between who and
who miles
the titans and the browns
i think the titans need them and the
browns also need them but i think the
titans need them maybe a little bit more
but the browns can pay him more
so that's why i would say those two
teams yeah i will
say the bills and the packers those are
the two teams i think it's going to come
down to i think he really wants to play
for the packers and if the money's close
i think he'll pick green bay but uh it's
still going to be a while he's one week
into free agency
we'll see how that plays out next one
big ben will be the steelers quarterback
this year if what and i am told
we must be specific okay i hope this is
specific enough i think
he will be their quarterback if they can
bring his cap number down to around
27 million and they can do that through
the extension and mike you've written
extensively about this and that explains
it far better than i could
say it but i think if they can bring
that cap number down to about 27 million
there
then that'll probably be close enough
where the steelers say
we can put enough around you and he says
that's enough
and that i can be comfortable with what
i'm making
i think that he will be the quarterback
of the steelers this year if
and only if the steelers objectively
believe they will be a contender
if he is on the roster if they do not
objectively believe they'll be a
contender and i mean super bowl
contender not playoff contender because
they'll be a playoff contender no matter
what they put together
they have to objectively believe they
will be a super bowl contender with ben
roethlisberger if they don't objectively
believe that
then i think they will move on from ben
roethlisberger whether they cut him
whether it's a mutual thing whether it's
a retirement where they don't ask him
for any money back whatever it is
i don't think he'll be with the team if
they don't believe they will be
a super bowl contender next which
quarterback
would you buy most stock in for 2021
matthew stafford jared goff carson wentz
or jalen hurts
matthew stafford and i don't think it's
close i think looking at that rams team
they are built right now to try to get
to a super bowl
and i think if we all know that sean
mcvay
is a really good schemer of offense and
now we can see what he can do
you know with that thing really unlocked
with the qb who has probably a little
bit of a higher ceiling than jared goff
even at matt stafford's age
i think that makes it not very close i
would go matthew stafford there for sure
i'm just fascinated by how that trade
when it becomes official march 17 401 pm
eastern
is going to help us figure out who's to
blame was it stafford or the lions was
it goff or mcvay
for the recent regression of the offense
and maybe everything works out maybe it
works out great for for both sides and
both quarterbacks have a rebirth but i
agree with you stafford is the stock
that i would buy
right now moving forward because of that
partnership with mcvay and that
rejuvenation
that mcvay is going to be feeling next
topic do devon white's comments about
the chiefs he was on fs1 earlier this
week saying hey
they shouldn't say anything about not
having their starting tackles for super
bowl 55
they didn't do anything to help them
five-man blocking 92 percent of the
time will that spark changes for the
chiefs miles
uh i think it depends on if they can get
their off their starting offensive line
in back and if they are healthy i think
if you have your starting left tackle
out there instead of mike remembers he's
your backup right tackle
and then you know you don't have to move
your guard out to tackle
and play him there i think that that
makes it a totally different scenario
now if the chiefs have to go back and
they don't have their starting offensive
lineman then yeah that probably should
prompt changes
but if you have your starting five that
are supposed to be out there then
maybe it's a different result because
you have guys that are playing up to
that caliber mike
yeah i i think the key is the changes
need to be made
at the back up position you got to have
tackles who can come in and get it done
when your starters get injured that's
the benefit of having a quarterback who
doesn't take every last dollar
money is left over to bolster the ranks
of the second string
also yeah schematically he got to be
ready to keep somebody in
to help block and not expect patrick
mahomes to run around with his hair on
fire for 497 yards in a 60-minute game
behind the line of scrimmage
trying to find someone open so i hope
those comments
are going to spark some changes i hope
that he didn't have to say it
to get the chiefs to look in the mirror
and spark some changes they're going to
have a hard time getting back to the top
of the mountain
make a bold prediction who will be the
next person or
group that tom brady takes a shot at on
social media
we mentioned that because of his one
minute video
where he dredges up the
various snippets from a full season of
criticism of things that deserved at the
time to be criticized now that he's
holding his seventh trophy
who's the next group or person who gets
it from tom brady
uh literally you and me from yesterday's
show when we started making tom petty
jokes
and you know i made free falling stop
dragging my heart around
references it's gonna be either us or i
don't know maybe somebody who said
something
you know not so nice about gronk before
but he's definitely going to take
another victory lap from winning this
ring at some point i wish it would be
belichick but i feel like it's more
likely to be you and me
i i'd like to think that he's not going
to do it again i'd like to think that he
realizes he shouldn't have done it
the other time that it does make him
look petty
but i do hope if he does it again he
uses
a tom petty track as the soundtrack
for that would make it perfect because
he's always
come off as self-aware so many of these
star athletes aren't
and that video made him look not
self-aware but if he would do it again
at least let us know that you recognize
you are being
tom petty and go ahead and play the tom
petty song and if the
the estate of tom petty sues you from
the song catalog
or whatever you got the money right to
check and move forward all right last
one
uh no okay good i'm it's not it's not
there was one more
that i thought was real it's not real
thank god
we'll be back with more pft live right
after this
pro football talk is brought to you by
verizon
5g built right
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports